امتنعاه لاعبه منتخب ايران عن عدم ترديد
النشيد الوطني قبل مباراتهم الافتتاحيه في
كاس العالم لكره القدم امام انجلترا في
اشاره دعم واضحه للاحتجاجات في ايران
وصمت كل عناصر تشكيله الاساسيه لايران
المكونه من 11 لاعبا اثناء عزف النشيد
الوطني في استاد خليفه الدولي فيما حجبت
تلفزيون الايراني صور لاعبين خلال البث
الحي لعصف النشيد الوطني قبل المباراه
يشار الى ان تشكيلته كانت فقدت عاطف
الجماهير في ايران حيث تهمهم كثيرون
بالانحياز الى حمله السلطات العنيفه ضد
المتظاهرين
هناك هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من القاهره
مصطفى بكري عضو مجلس النواب المصريه اهلا
بك ومن امستردام يعقوب سعيد البحث في شان
الايراني اهلا بكم
نسمعها لان ابدا من امستردام معك سيد
يعقوب سيد يعقوب هذه التحركات او مشاهدناه
على الاقل على مستوى اللاعبين من صمت
اناشيد الوطني لايران الى اي مدى يمكن لي
هذه الحركات ان تساعد الاحتجاجات في
الداخل
تحيه طيبه لك تعليق
طبعا هذه الحركات هي تساعد المحتاجين
كثيرا باعتبار انها تصل صوتهم الى العالم
خاصه في ظل هذه يعني الاستضافه الدوليه في
ظل هذا الانتباه العالمي للمباراه التي
وقعت في قطر فاكيد هي تساعد كثيرا ولكن
علينا ان نعي بان ايضا ال ال الشعوب في
ايران هي فرحت ايضا بهذه النتيجه مما يعني
زمان الذي يحاول الذي يحاول في هذا النظام
استغلال الكره لامتصاص غضب الجماهير من
خلال انتصارات سواء حقيقيه او وهميه انت
ايضا الجماهير كانوا غير راضيين على اداء
همم الفريق خلال الفتره الماضيه حيث انه
ملتقوا بالرئيس روحاني همم دون ان يتطرقوا
لمواضيع مهمه التي لها علاقه واصله
بالاحتجاجات في ايران كذلك اللاعب
الايراني
الذي سجل هدفين امه في سابق قدم التصريح
لفارس لوكاله الانباء يا فارس وقالت فيها
بان في حال ابني سجل اهداف ضد بريطانيا او
امريكا سوف اهدي هذا
الانتصار الى همم ضحايا الذين وقعوا في
العمليه الارهابيه في شيراز بمعنى هم هذه
المراه ربما ابنها يتبنون فكره خامنئي
بانه ما يحصل هو مؤامره من بريطانيا ولكن
بعيدا عن ذلك ما حصل
اكيد ساهم بشكل كبير لراينا بان الاعلام
العالمي والكثير من الدول غطت هذه الحادثه
عبر
في هذا الجانب ما له استاذه مصطفى همم
بكري استاذ مصطفى همم هل همم
هذه الحركات يمكن ان تؤثر همم من نافذه
اعلاميه على ما يحدث او على تاثير او على
ضغط دولي قابل ان يكون في قادم الايام على
داخل يعني عنده مشاهده لانه كل الوكالات
التقطت هذه الصور ونشرتها وتحدثت عنها
الفريق السعودي بفوز على الارجنتين وانا
ايضا الفريق التونسي بالتعادل مع الفريق
الدنماركي ودي اعتقد النداء يعني احدث
حاله من السعاده والارتياح لدى كل ابناء
الامه العربيه واكد على وحده الامه التصور
حليفه كل الفرق العربيه ونحن سعداء في
الواقع بهذا الانتصارات صحيح ان شاء الله
بالتاكيد لم تكن اييي هذه الوقفه وهذا
الموقف وعدم ترديد النشيد الوطني من قبل
ال 11 لاعبا صدفه او مفاجاه لان رئيس
الفريق قال ذلك واكد عليه ربما قبل اربعه
ايام ثم ايضا جاء عشيه المباراه واكد على
هذا الامر واعتقد ان ذلك يعكس ثلاث امور
مهمه الامر الاول هو كسر حاجز الخوف لدى
الايرانيين ليس فقط لدى
القيادات والجماهير الشعبيه ولكن ايضا لدى
النخب التي يفترض ان تكون مرتبطه بالنظام
بشكل قوي ومن بينه همم فريق همم الكره
الذي شارك في المونديال الامر الثاني هو
التوافق عندما يتوافق احد عشر شخصا ربما
لديهم انتماءات عراقيه متعدده ولديهم
مواقف سواء كانت وطنيه او سياسيه مختلفه
ويتم التوافق فهذا يعكس التركيبه الشعبيه
والسكانيه للايرانيين جميعا الامر الثالث
هو ان هناك تاكيد بالفعل على ان حاله
الغضب الشعبي تجاه هذه الممارسات وتحديدا
بعد
تعذيب ومقتل ماسه امينه يؤكد بالفعل على
ان الشارع الايراني
مستمر وهو مستمر منذ اكثر من شهرين عندما
انطلقت التظاهرات في الرابعه عشر من
سبتمبر ويبدو وامتداد هذه الاحتجاجات الى
حوالي 155 مدينه والى 142 جامعه وينتج
عنها حوالي 419 قتيلا حتى الان كل ذلك
يؤكد بالفعل ويعكس ان هناك توافقا بين
النقب وما بين الجماهير الشعبيه وهذا هذه
الرساله يعني نظام الحكم في ايران
في مستوى المعين ولكن يبقى سؤال مطروح
استاذ يعقوب همم هل تداخلت الملفات
السياسيه مع الملفات هل تعتقد بانه همم
يجب ان تطرح مثل هكذا شعارات او ان تطرح
مثل هكذا ملفات او ردت فعل او مواقع في
محافر رياضيه او يجب الفصل في هذا الموضوع
لانه همم كانت هناك كان هناك دعم لهذا
الموقف وكانت هناك كذلك انتقادات ولو
بنسبه المعينه ولكن كانت هناك اعتقادات
كذلك تبعناها
السياسي اودعنا
نسميه الدعم ل همم لحقوق الانسان
وملف الرياضه وليس جديد وحصل خلال ال- ال-
يعني الفترات السابقه كثيرا مع فرق كثيره
ولكن حتى على الجانب الايراني حصل ذلك همم
رئيس الاتحاديه للملاكمه قبل اسبوع تقريبا
عندما كان في اسبانيا للمشاركه مع الفريق
هو ايضا قدم استقالته من هذه الاتحاديه
الايرانيه انا اقصد وقرر ان يبقى في
اسبانيا حتى دعما للمحتاجين في ايران
وربما كل الفريق سوف يبقى في اسبانيا حتى
هذه اللحظه لم يقرره لذلك التداخل هو يجب
ان يحصل خاصه عندما يكون الامر في غايه
الاهميه مثل ما يحصل الان في ايران
بالتالي هؤلاء الرياضيين هم من المواطنين
هؤلاء الرياضيين هم ايضا
الحريه
يعقوب الى عدم تسييس الرياضه
فا الى اي مدى كذلك هذا الطرح لا زال
موجود في ظل كل هذه المتغيرات التي نعيشها
انا لا اتصور هذا التشييسا بقدر ما هو دعم
لحقوق الانسان ده في دوله ينتهك فيها حقوق
الانسان قتل فيها اكثر من 52 طفله كذلك
الرياضيين في ايران اليوم يعتقلون يعني
الكثير من الرياضيين تم استدعائهم همم
الرياضيه الايرانيه علي دايما سحب جواز
سفر بمعنى هم عليهم ايضا ان يتعاطفون مع
زملائهم وبالتالي عليهم ان يتعاطفون مع
مواطنهم فهؤلاء اللاعبينهم ايضا هم ايضا
بالتالي مواطنين هم ايضا حقوقهم مسلوبه
فلذلك عندما يتعاطفون عندما يعبرون عن
تضامنهم مع ما يحصل في ايران هذا ليس
التسييسا بقدر ما هو تعبير عن واقع يحصل
بشكل يومي في ايران
هناك احد فاصل همم بسيط جدا بين التاسيس
والدفاع عن حقوق الانسان ما رايك سيد ما
استطيع يعني منذ قليل اتيت على نقطه مهمه
قلت بانه همم الموقف الذي تبعناه من
اللاعبين الايرانيين يبرز بان هناك قيودا
قد فلتت وبانه هناك همم عمليه اجماع على
موقف واحد ولكن هل هذا يضعنا في اطار ان
ما فعلوه متاح وقد ياتي بفائده اعتقد
ان قوانين الفيفا معروفه ولا يسمح بتسيس
المباريات الرياضيه او رفع شعارات معينه
كل ما تم هو همم وقفه صمت ربما لم يحمل اي
من اللاعبين الرياضيين شعار معين ولكن
وقفه الصمت هذه همم والنشيد الوطني ربما
التليفزيون الايراني رفض ان يضيع هذه
اللقطه ولكنها رساله لكل المواطنين اننا
معكم ولسنا بعدينا عنكم باي حال من
الاحوال واعتقد ان هذه الرساله ستؤجج
كثيرا الاحتجاجات وستعطي الثقه لكل مواطن
همم ايران وخاصه ان هذا الفريق قد هوجم
بعد لقائه مع الرئيس الايراني ولكن همم
هذا ما يعتمد في نفوس كل الايرانيين
الرافدين والذين رفعوا شعارات منها
هي شعارات ضده وغير ذلك من الامور واعتقد
ان ما حدث تكون له تداعيات كبرى على هذه
المسيره باستمرارها واظن ان الاعلام
العالمي اا عندما تطرق لهذا الامر تطرق
وربطه بالاحتجاجات وخطوره هذه الاحتجاجات
واسباب هذه
مصطفى يعني حضرتك تقول بانهم لم يرفعوا
شعارات طيب ولكن تعلم حظرتك بان نشيد
الوطني يمثل همم المواطنه يمثل الهويه همم
نشيد الوطني همم ركيزه من ركائز الدوله
وكان لاعبين هنا يقولون بانه كل صبرنا
تخطى حتى الهويه تخطى حتى موضوع المواطنه
همم ونحن سنعبر عن موقفنا هذا الى اي مدى
يضر او على الاقل يؤثر في نظره الخارج
للنظام الايراني في حضن ذاته
اولا ليه سمعنا عدم ترديد النشيد الوطني
جنبنا الى جنب ما عزف هذا النشيد معناه
كفر بالوطن او المجتمع بدليل ان العلم
الايراني احرق من بعض المحتجين ولم يكن
الهدف بالاساس الاساءه الى العالم
الايراني بقدر انه نوع من انواع الاحتجاج
الذي رفع في هذا الوقت احتجاجا على
ممارسات النظام في هذا الامر واتصور ان
الرساله التي ارادوا ان يقولها وصلت للكل
ووصلت للعالم واعتقد ان ال يعني لم يعد
امامهم من خيار اذا همم عادوا الى ايران
فهم همم محتبونا بالشعب حتى ومستعدون لاي
عقوبات واذا بقوا في الخارج في رسالتهم هي
لكل العالم كما حدث في اسبانيا ايضا
وغيرها من عوامل الاحتجاج التي تعبر عن
نفسها وتوقع ان ذلك ستعقبه ربما حركه
استقلالات من رياضيين او سياسيين او دب
ياسين في الفتره المقبله لان التازم
الاوضاع يزداد يوما عن يوم واصبح الامر
خارج سيطرت السلطه الايرانيه التي تمتلك
اثنين مليون
مسلح يستطيعه بالفعل ان يقنعه وان يفعلوا
المستحيل ولكن هذه حركه شعبيه عارمه تمتد
كل يوم الى مزيد من المدن وتشمل كل الفئات
الاجتماعيه بالاسنان
عند عوده من هم بداخل الايراني او من
يعيشون في داخل الايراني عند عودتهم
لايران سيكون هنا محميين من الشعب او ربما
سيتعرضون لما يتعرض له امثاله فدخل
الايراني من اعتقالات من محاولات القمع
تقصدين بان الفريق الفريق الايراني نفسه
اتصور يعني بالتالي هم مثلا علي دايي كما
اشرت سابقا سبقهم في موقفه المعارض لهذا
النظام وعبر عن موقفه عده مرات فهما اقصى
ما استطاعوا ان يعملوا سحبوا جواز سفره
ومنعوه من السفر خارج ايران لا يتصور
العقوبه على الفريق على اعضاء الفريق
الايراني سوف تكون اكبر من ذلك باعتبار
انه هنالك يعني انتباه دولي هنالك مراقبه
دوليه للصحف العالميه وكذلك الصحف المحليه
لما يحصل لما يحصل لهم عند عودتهم الى
البلاد فلذلك هذه يعني لا اتصورت ستكون
ستكون العقوبه اكثر من ذلك ولكن هم استطاع
يعيد الثقه بينهم وبين الموجودين
حتى ولو بشكل بسيط يعني لم ليست الثقه
اعاده كم بشكل كامل لانه ما عملوه خلال
الفتره السابقه صمتهم همم يعني كانت اثمن
اخيرا بالنسبه للثوار ولكن اعاده الثقه
هذا سوف يعني لهم الكثير بالنسبه للداخلين
بالتالي اللاعبين هم سوف يتلقون دعمهم
دائما من الشعوب من الشعوب التي تدعمها
ليس من الانظمه
على كل سنبقى في متابعه تاثيرات هذا
الموقف وهذه المواقف ساعدت بوجودك
بوجودكما معنا من القاهره مصطفى بكري عضو
مجلس النواب المصري شكرا لك وامنه مستر
رامي يعقوب سعيد الباحث في شان الايراني
شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]